it is time to go in your business for
another up close look at our economy
here in the valley and we're joined as
you see there
by vegas chamber president and ceo mary
beth seawalled
uh by zoom this morning mary beth good
to see you once again
good to see you john thanks for having
me so we're seeing uh capacity limits
increase restrictions are decreasing
across the valley
obviously local businesses have been
clamoring for that for for a long time
what kind of a reception are you getting
from members of the chamber
members of the chamber are pretty
excited we're seeing people coming back
to las vegas and
tourism and businesses are picking up
a lot of hotels we're at capacity the
last two weekends
room rates have gone on significantly
and we're also
seeing a lot of strong visitation
because of things like spring break
and you know shows are beginning to
reopen now that we're at 50
capacity and conventions are starting to
come back
with world of concrete in early june so
these are all really great
signs and it means that the local
businesses are
uh that serve our visitors are also
feeling really optimistic
too so and you know it's going to take
some time to fully recover and
return to full capacity but all
indications are that we will and sooner
than later so of course as you know john
we have to be mindful of covid19
and continue to follow the guidelines to
keep everybody safe but
absolutely clearly people want to get
back out and do things
and come to las vegas so really excited
there's definitely this sense of
optimism i've certainly noticed it
around town over the last uh maybe month
or so
with some of these restrictions that
have been lifted 2020 was extremely hard
a lot of businesses unfortunately have
not made it here to 2021.
let's try and look ahead a little bit to
2021 and how long of a recovery we're
really in
in line for well you're absolutely right
john you know that and there is a lot to
be optimistic about and we are and our
members are
a lot of new properties are opening up
as you know including
uh circa in october of this last year
virgin hotel last weekend uh and resorts
world in the next few months
as well of course as the las vegas
convention center so being on the lbcba
board of directors i'm particularly
interested in the lbcv the convention
center
so and we also have special events
coming back nfl football
uh the life is beautiful festival we
have nascar
pvr and nfr and these are going to help
bring leisure travelers back to las
vegas
and and of course meetings and
conventions are coming back like we said
world of concrete in june we've got the
magic show in august
and so much more this fall so we're
really looking uh forward to a rebound
so again we've got the tourism slowly
starting to come back to las vegas we
talked a lot here about what's happening
on the strip in downtown and the
conventions and so forth but
how long might it take for some of that
to find its way that money that income
to find its way
to local businesses the mom and pop
shops that aren't on the strip that are
not in the resort corridor
well you know john it doesn't take long
we are already seeing our local
businesses
more optimistic about the future local
employers are already rehiring
new businesses are opening and at the
same time our
unemployment rate is going down it's now
under about 10
in las vegas which is still too high
mind you but it has been steadily
declining
since late last summer so while this is
is good news too we have to be mindful
that we need to diversify our southern
nevada economy
so that we're less dependent on those
visitors but um
you know we're just so optimistic again
people are rehiring
events uh basketball is uh coming back
we've got all kinds of sports
and then one of the chambers uh
priorities is workforce training john to
make sure that our local workers are
trained
with the skill set that new and emerging
industries need
right like health care industry or
logistics and
some of the most in demand jobs don't
even require a college degree so
it could be a certificate from a
community college so
these are the things that we're
prioritizing at the vegas chamber
is helping to open the door for
sustainable careers in industries
like healthcare and some of those
industries john that are less
susceptible to these fluctuations
let's switch gears a little bit mary
beth and talk about uh a partnership
that vegas chamber has going on
with an organization in town we've
profiled before called hope for
prisoners uh
april the month of second chances that
seems like the the driving force behind
this partnership
it is john you know the vegas chamber is
really proud to be partners with hope
for prisoners and john ponder
because of their extraordinary success
in helping
the formerly incarcerated individuals
develop their life
and their job skills so that they can
come back and rebuild their lives
hope for prisoners helps with re-entry
into the community
they provide job training and long-term
support services as people work to
reclaim their lives and families
and standing in the community quite
frankly you know we've all
needed second chances at some point in
our life and hope for prisoners
graduates
are absolutely outstanding employees
and at the same time this program gives
companies benefits like tax breaks and
payroll assistance
so not only can these employees benefit
your business
by giving them you can you know benefit
your business by giving these folks a
second chance but you can help our
community
um reduce its rate of recidivism and
help families succeed and thrive
so we're just really excited about this
partnership we're also going to be
co-hosting a virtual job fair with hope
for prisoners
and workforce connections and that's
coming up on april 2nd so it's a great
yeah hobo prisoners does a lot of great
work john ponder and the rest of the
team there he's done
quite a quite a lot since he's uh since
he's started that non-profit
let's finally talk about the legislative
session it's under way up in carson city
there's a lot of bills obviously it's
still a long way to go to get to the end
of the session here
what is on the vegas chambers list of
bills that perhaps you're either
interested in going forward or
interested in maybe not going forward
well the vegas chambers government
affairs team is on the ground in carson
city
monitoring more than 600 bills
now the legislature is closed to the
public because of the pandemic and
while we you know we understand the need
to keep people safe
this closed environment creates a lot of
obstacles for citizens to participate
which is so dangerous for open and
transparent government
so we're hoping that the legislature
will open very soon
you know there are some good proposals
for the region that the chamber has
supported
ab106 dedicates more money to pandemic
the pets grants pandemic emergency
technical support of course that helps
employers and non-profits
we've also been in favor of ab 184 which
is uh from
creates the office of small business
advocacy
but there are several bills that are
quite frankly very dangerous john and
they would hurt employees and
employers sb 200 would require employers
to take money out of an employee's
paycheck and put it in a
state retirement fund and then
you know there are other ones uh also
this session
you know the chamber is seeing a lot of
bills that will have compounding
negative effects on
nevada's economic recovery uh with more
mandates and
and regulations and reporting to state
agencies
it's tough for for small businesses so
we're really there trying to advocate on
behalf of all of our business across the
state
just to follow up on that you talked
about the retirement account what what
is
wrong with an employer doing that for
presumably an employee or what would be
wrong with uh with that
specific measure well certainly john we
are in favor of retirement plans and and
saving for the future
um this would this would happen
automatically so
just like social security paycheck
deductions this would mean
less take-home pay for nevada's families
an
employee could opt out of it um but they
would have to opt out rather than
opt-in and so we're just trying to be
very careful that
employees don't uh automatically have
these funds taken out of their
out of their paycheck without either
without knowing it or knowing that they
can opt out
one of hundreds of bills that you and i
and everybody else are watching up in
carson city right now mary beth seawall
from the vegas chamber thank you for
joining us this morning we appreciate it
thank you john